Allora ragazzi siamo a dotonbori eh
sempre è super pieno di gente e ho
notato che c'è uno spider-man che entra
in una vongola
si parte però Osaka wow wow
siamo arrivati all'hotel di Osaka ci
sono gli ascensori come in Death parade
decidi quale dobbiamo andare queste qua
scegli bene che poi siamo nella merda
incredibile ve lo giuro ragazzi se non
sapete cosa sto parlando per favore
chiudete il video Grazie ragazzi Ma in
che cazzo di albergo siamo finiti Ma
scusate ma chi è che ho prenotato sto
albergo io non voglio spendere 8 milioni
di euro qua Allora ragazzi tutto quello
che c'è in questo albergo è strano e
sembra uscito da Inuyasha 524 è la mia
stanza quindi siamo qua al labirinto sto
coso incredibile e adesso spuntano le
bambine di Shining però versione
giapponese Ed eccoci qua Ah Ah bella
bella umile finculi cuscini Ma lo senti
No ragazzi ce Lecco come può esserci
Ecco in una stanza intito un attimo cioè
l'eco ma lo sentite che bordello
Incredibile ci sono questi simpatico
Questa è la vera lasciate sta' ragazzo o
tre ore di viaggio anzi di più ci sono
delle simpatiche scarpette
anche queste me le foto Vabbè ragazzi
non male Ah vabbè dai dai Scusatemi che
poi ogni volta allora aspetta qua
ecco
non ho più l'età
Allora ragazzi mi hanno dato questa
moneta che se noi la mettiamo
all'interno lui ci tira fuori un drink
tra questi Io bevo veramente poco però
siccome è gratis a tutto più sapore ne
abbiamo uno al giorno per la permanenza
qua Quindi per adesso vediamo io vado di
sa che ovviamente
Porca [__] lo sapevo
ragazzi Qua sparano alle cose non ho
capito bene facciamolo Allora
scemo ma è scemo Ragazzi io stavo
sparando
do it you Chris certo
in gomma bella
[Musica]
ho vinto però eh Ho vinto questo
Ho vinto questi due sono una fragola
mezza Secondo me Allora ragazzi a parte
il fatto che Stiamo spendendo non so
quanto il cibo Grazie Dan ci porti qua
ci hanno portato mi ha obbligato lui Se
vogliamo dirla tutta Sì a prendere
questo che dalle foto sembrava bello
effettivamente è uguale alle foto che è
incredibile Quindi l'ho preso anche io
però non capisco il perché ci sia un
cracker fai un salato Tra l'altro
infilato dentro non so che concetto di
dolce loro abbiano capito anche questa
roba qua
Io prima mi sa che dei fonsi qua dirò
neanche com'è ragazzi è buono cosa provo
il cracker proviamo il cracker creerà la
panna è buono eh Intanto mangio anche il
prosciutto con la Nutella quando mi
sveglio
[Musica]
Ma
perché non vuol dire niente robetta Rosa
Sembra surimi prima ancora di essere
lavorato
[Musica]
ma non scherzo se sono andati tutti
perché lo sapevano che ci hanno preso
questo Cos'è Vabbè quando arriva il
gelato però non
[Musica]
non c'è niente non c'è niente che mi
aspetto di Sapori tutto diverso e non
saprei che voto dare a sta roba
basta stop per favore classico treno
giapponese Va bene e non so perché però
ok tutto giusto quello che è bello tutto
giusto quello che vedo ragazzi siamo
arrivati a Nara che è il posto dove
appunto Il cerbiatti sono cerbiatti
questi perché facciamo anche quella di
merda non cani sicuramente non sono cani
vedete non ci sono barriere loro possono
alzarsi e andare in giro Adesso è
mattina quindi stanno qua però dopo li
vedremo anche in giro probabilmente nei
negozi nei combini in banca
al Parco Sempione oh scusate ma un
saluto
Va bene come volete selfie
a posto
e le [__] ce l'abbiamo fatta troppo
ridere perché c'è la bancarella qua lui
è qua ma non ci va a prenderli qua
Aspetta che la gente compri per poi per
poi farsi dare da mangiare perché non
non vanno direttamente dalla banca
questo perché sono Sio del business
questi qua aspetto che la gente compri
perché loro non ha percentuale se no non
si spiega perché Guardate non lui non la
tocca la bancarella Aspetta che loro
comprino e adesso Jay ha speso i suoi
soldi e ora i cervi saranno qua a godere
di questo prelibato pasto offerto la j
che ti dirò che non sembra male Infatti
se sei un uomo lo provi
Vai vai Eccolo qua
Eccolo qua Eh a me non mi hai mai
offerto la scena eh Vedo che No no
grazie va bene così
ma quando fanno così con la testa della
serie dammene Ancora brutto bastardo c'è
proprio questo movimento di testa che
significa questo
ingordo ma che cazzo no è business sa
che se li finisci li compri di nuovo e
poi lui ha la percentuale mica so scemi
oh Maestri del business e fratelli io
c'ho solo l'acqua questo ti posso dare è
Jake
a me fa paura a darglielo non so perché
c'è un Cuor di Leone ed è il giorno in
cui il buon J Diventa uomo vai Eccolo
qua
ti ho mentito non l'avevo provata
buona
è così che si conquista la selvaggina
ragazzi foto per Instagram
giovane ed ecco il classico caso di
Cervi di Nara che attraversano le
strisce pedonali simpatica questa cosa
che tutti in gruppo aspettano il
semaforo Non si capisce come sia
possibile Però succede questa cosa
ragazzi siamo tornati uno dei miei punti
preferiti Appunto nel Giappone che è la
Mi sa che mi servi tu qua dove cazzo si
chiama Nara però di qua Questo città dei
Daini
noi Siamo stronzi Vabbè lasciamo perdere
Comunque gli animali che non sono cani
Comunque siamo qua in questo tempio
gigantesco a Nara che appunto
ospita il daiduzu cos'è il daibuzzo è il
Buddha gigante che è grosso quanto
quello che c'è a kamakura che mi sa che
l'anno ne avevo fatto il logo di questo
Vabbè comunque è un Buddha
grosso che però diversamente era quello
di camera quella sta all'interno di
questo mega tempio e adesso vedrete la
boss Fight Aspettate che arriva c'è
sempre il problema che vi invito non si
capisce
sicuro che questo è grosso ragazzi è
grosso
ha detto che non non Guardatelo troppo
perché poi andate in trance e fate dei
viaggi mentali incredibili è veramente
un Buddha grosso più grosso non si
capisce quanto è grosso ragazzi cioè dal
video veramente non si percepisce per
niente ma è veramente gigante titanico
un orecchio e grosso due metri e mezzo
mi ha detto un orecchio
quindi
immaginatevi che un occhio è largo un
metro Secondo me quindi immaginatevi una
persona
distesa in orizzontale lì un pelo più
lungo sarebbe una persona arriva fino ai
capelli ma questa vuoi perché
praticamente è grosso sto coso è gigante
bellissimo Vai distruggi Questo è il
cartello esplicativo con le quattro
mosse che andrò a fare allora il morso
il morso il morso che è una delle
Monster standard si sblocca a livello 15
kicking al 25 Esatto Dashing capito
insieme all'attacco rapido può fare
Dashing e poi batti batti in testa
l'ultimo
Ovviamente per imparare la quinta devono
dimenticare una di queste certo non
sappiamo ancora perché nessun danno è
arrivata a livello Abbastanza alto da
poter disimparare una massa imparare
però ci arriveremo ragazzi ci arriveremo
pochi ragazzi è successa una cosa
stranissima sono uscito dalla stanza per
andare a fare colazione Sono tornato
un'oretta dopo e la stanza l'hanno
rifatta perfetto Sono venuto qua che mi
serviva dovevo prendere l'adattatore no
l'adattatore per il caricatore che mi
serve per il regola barbari vengo qua e
vedo che l'adattatore è attaccato è che
molto gentili Mi hanno attaccato il
telefono al caricatore wireless il
problema Il problema grosso è che il
telefono e questo non questo che state
vedendo questo con cui sto registrando
Questo è il mio telefono e questo di chi
cazzo è c'è un telefono che non è mio
Cioè questo sono entrati mi hanno
rifatto la camera e mi hanno poggiato un
telefono che non è mio qui in carica
pensando di farmi anche un favore della
serie A Guarda il poverino L'ha lasciato
là glielo metto in carica si sono messi
il loro telefono in carica nella mia
stanza e l'hanno lasciato qui Ma cosa
c'è un telefono ma cosa vedo che cos'è
sta roba qua questo non è il mio non è
il mio telefono Questo non è il mio
telefono non lo è
c'è un'aquila
nepalipatro Messenger non si può neanche
sbloccare perché non non ho idea neanche
di come ti aspetto che qualcuno chiami
Perché non so non c'è la SIM non so che
fare ragazzi cioè non posso neanche
sbloccarlo per capire di chi è e mandare
un messaggio posso farmi dei selfie però
ok
in carica il suo telefono nella mia
stanza e l'ha perso lui ragazzi guardate
che vista pazzesca che c'è da qua
incredibile
Comunque ragazzi sono qua adesso andiamo
a Kyoto cioè Siamo a Kyoto e
teoricamente ci facciamo un bel primo
giro di questa magica città anzi li
porto in giro io sono stato già tre
volte Questa è la quarta
ragazzi siamo al
fujimiths Paris
and That's The Temple of the main Temple
You can see you don't let Snow Funny
temps
e qua vendono
granchio che le Bun ogni volta vengo qua
mangio sto granchio che se lo infilano
in sti bastoni enormi Ed eccolo qua il
crabm Fish mix 800 Yen ti danno una
stecca di granchio molto buono Se venite
a Kyoto provatelo o leggermente
esagerato Effettivamente si vede però ho
fame allora
Se vi ricordate ho visto il ragno più
grosso della mia vita c'è un ragno
enorme attaccato a uno di questi pali
raga fa veramente è la cosa più schifosa
che abbiamo No vabbè dai raga andiamo
via per favore e siamo appunto ritornati
qui per combattere le nostre paure tanto
ho la mia squadra tipo gli Avengers che
mi difendono Intendo la signora
soffiatore perché ho scalato una
montagna Praticamente siamo ancora il
fucili binari ma abbiamo preso un
sentiero se avete visto le mie storie di
Instagram che ho messo in questi giorni
sapete di cosa sto parlando un sentiero
che non c'era nessuno Siamo andati
avanti a camminare per circa un'ora e
mezza e siamo in un punto stranissimo vi
faccio vedere e non c'è nessuno cioè
letteralmente Qui non c'è nessuno
siamo arrivati noi dopo un'ora e mezza
di camminata non c'è niente c'è il vuoto
cosmico come se fossi dentro la città
incantata cioè sono scomparsi tutti e io
trovo solo queste sembrano rovine e
quello che nei videogiochi quando
schiacci X ti dà poi dei poteri Cioè
veramente sembra di giocare a tread out
non so se lo ricordate c'era roba strana
ragazzi cioè veramente sono entrato in
un posto
che non che non so cosa sia ma da ore
sono qua cioè proprio non passa una
persona un'anima viva da un'ora non c'è
nessuno non si sente No ragazzi visto
veramente preoccupata anche i ragazzi ho
perso di vista perché comunque anche
loro siano cioè sono venuto qua con i
Pantellas a un certo punto però non ho
visto più neanche loro Quindi loro
saranno dispersi più come me oh E dopo
ore di cammino civiltà non c'è una
persona ancora però c'è un cartello
Allora abbiamo Ecco qua a monteinari 150
metri
1450 metri di altezza siamo a quanto
pare tutto sto casino qua e devo andare
da quella parte là Intanto c'è Jay l'ho
ritrovati ragazzi Vabbè c'è una
macchinetta che sta per esplodere ma
quello è un discorso Uh c'è un gatto
salendo da boh saranno lo so da una vita
sento Bear Grizzly Come fai a non essere
neanche stanco niente piccante cammini
come se niente fosse scaglie le montagne
Madonna io non ce la fa più Eccoli qua
gli spavaldi impavidii non si sa dov'è
finito Allora ragazzi siamo tornati in
un punto familiare Almeno quello ragazzi
inspiegabilmente non so come non so se
abbiamo fatto una sorta di rito per il
quale siamo tornati nel mondo normale
però siamo tornati dove c'è civiltà Beh
diciamo che questo è un punto un po' più
suggestivo è un punto veramente carino
Non chiedetemi come ci si arriva perché
non lo so siamo in giro da stamattina Un
miracoloso sia ambivi Quindi figuriamoci
è stato bellissimo è stata la volta in
assoluto dove me la sono goduta di più
perché siamo andati fino in cima al
Monte tutto totalmente an expected
perché abbiamo preso delle strade che
non erano quelle console per arrivare in
cima ed è stata tutta una bella sorpresa
allora
Praticamente ci sono un sacco di gatti e
c'è anche ci sono anche i nomi Sora a
Niki io voglio Bob e quello nero Vediamo
se lo becco Certo che fare il video a
questa cosa mentre un banana succo in
mano è impossibile c'è un gatto che sta
scappando è scappato e non lo sto
facendo scappare Cosa faccio sono
bloccato Sono bloccato Sono bloccato
bellissimo molto carino Adesso sta
dentro a dire Guarda J come è a suo agio
questo ha giocato troppo Assassin's
Creed adesso salta sopra Jacopo
attenzione Guardalo Ecco si appresta si
appresta all'uccisione della Stealth voi
cari in testa no invece siamo arrivati
alla meritata a cena dopo aver salito un
miliardo di gradini
le scale tenendoti la carne di Kobe in
mano comunque a prescindere da questo
Questa è la carne di Kobe e cioè Quale
di queste due cose quale Ugly perfetto
bene non so fare i video Allora
praticamente questa parte è la più
costosa Non è vero Costano tutte e due
uguali stiamo pagando un sacco di soldi
fortuna che è paga J quindi ehm Grazie
Jack Grazie mille applaudirei anch'io ma
devo tenere il telefono vediamo com'è
questa carne di Kobe e di Ugly in realtà
sono buone però Kobe fa più Click
[Musica]
ho appena mangiato 12 euro buonissimo
Ragazzi cosa stra divertente Stamattina
ci siamo svegliati e noi abbiamo il
caffè incluso con la stanza ci han detto
Sì sì prego prego andate a farvelo già
che te lo fai tu è strano ma come te lo
fai letteralmente un laboratorio sai
chimica come cazzo fa
dopo due ore Ecco qua il nostro caffè Ma
signori colpo di scena colpo di scena
e infine ragazzi facciamo un bel test di
questo io capolavoro che abbiamo fatto
stamattina
il caffè più merdoso via abbia mai
bevuto ragazzi siamo tornati nel punto
che prediligo di più del Giappone Per
quanto mi riguarda perché è una cosa in
realtà molti Milan Ma che cazzo stai a
dì però a me piace a me piace che è la
vista che c'è su Kobe cos'è Kobe la
città dove c'è appunto la carne di Kobe
non è la prefettura di cover però
facciamo una città si chiama Kobe come
la carne e c'è questa vista che adesso
vi farò vedere che merita un sacco
vedete Jay che è già eccitato prendete
nota ragazzi Quando venite in Giappone
deve venire qua questa è la ruota
panoramica e qua c'è tutta la vista di
Kobe che questa città splendida e si
illumina Tutta appena cala il sole alle
8 mi pare Cioè proprio un orario preciso
in cui tipo quando dici Alexa Accendi
salotto si accende tutta la città e
Eccoci qua tutto calcolato ragazzi è
partita una soundtrack mentre siamo
passati qua sotto forse c'era un sensore
lì
è partito questo
e siamo tutti qua incantati per questa
cosa che è successa Non so cosa sia
successo ragazzi sta cambiando colore
incredibile
succede No devo allargare Scusate raga
non si vedrà un cazzo in questo video Ho
provato a mettere il grandangolo
ma ritmo Disney lumination cos'è dove
eravamo a fare il video Prima ero qua a
far vedere a mangiare la vista che sia
da questo e siamo venuti qua è partito
come siamo passati di qua è partita
questa cosa
[Musica]
si scioglie la nostra compagnia no Era
per dire che questo è l'ultimo video di
Osaka torniamo a Tokyo domani vedrete il
finale sostanzialmente del nostro
viaggio nel prossimo video perché
saranno gli ultimi giorni a Tokyo e il
rientro a casa Purtroppo questo viaggio
sta per concludersi ma mi sono goduto
ogni istante è stato bellissimo Peccato
per i compagni di viaggio che non sono
al massimo
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un bel mi
piace e noi ci rivediamo con un prossimo
video Beh ragazzi